l'enfer s'éveille au front monde un
avant goût
de ce qui l'attend
nous avons une mission monsieur howard
c'est cet homme l'art celui de mes fils
y ont tué le septième fils d'un septième
fils
nos villes sont tombées toi seul peut
mettre fin à son règne de ténèbres tout
ce qu'il te faudra est déjà en toi c'est
un engagement que je ne puis prendre tu
vis dans un monde nouveau où les
légendes les cauchemars sont réels et
qu'elle est donc notre rôle nous
combattons l'obscur où qu'ils se cachent
comment on combat à gobelins ont leur
combat par ont fui
mon pouvoir se renforcent ma s'ouvrait
le monde humain s'il faudra si tu vois
une sorcière tu là nous ne sommes pas
toutes aussi pernicieuses et l'obscurité
est en toi je ne suis pas comme vous toi
et moi serons être de ce monde c'est
votre plus importante épreuve rejoignent
ouais moi voir ce que tu es